A.
Kvantové počítače jsou velmi citlivé na šum,
rušení, která způsobují chyby
v jejich výpočtech, ale nový výzkum ukazuje,
že hlučné kvantové počítače IBM se shodují s přesnými klasickými metodami
ve verifikovatelných režimech a překonávají sofistikované klasické
aproximační metody v obou verifikovatelných
i neverifikovatelných režimech
pro náročný simulační experiment.
Jak to dělají? Používají speciální techniku
pro práci se šumem
v kvantových systémech – říká se tomu mitigace chyb.
S technikou mitigace chyb
použitou v tomto experimentu spouštíme naše výpočty
a postupně zvyšujeme šum.
Pak extrapolujeme zpět k nulovému šumu.
Tato práce nás přibližuje o krok blíže k užitečnému kvantovému počítání
my